Welcome to the presentation
on solving inequalities,
or I guess you call them
algebra inequalities.
So let's get started.
If I were to tell you that,
well, let's just say x is
greater than 5, right?
So x could be 5.01, it could be
5.5, it could be a million.
It just can't be 4, or 3, or 0,
or negative 8, and actually,
just for convenience,
let's actually draw that
on the number line.
That's the number line.
And if this is 5, x can't be
equal to 5, so we draw a big
circle here, and then we would
color in all the values
that x could be.
So x could be just the small--
it could be 5.0000001.
It just has to be a little bit
bigger than 5, and any of those
would satisfy it, right?
So let's just write some
numbers that satisfy.
6 would satisfy it, 10
would satisfy it, 100
would satisfy it.
Now, if I were to multiply, or
I guess divide, both sides of
this, I guess we could say,
equation or this inequality
by negative 1, I want to
understand what happens.
So what's the relation between
negative x and negative 5?
When I say what's the relation,
is it greater than or is
it less than negative 5?
Well, 6 is a value
that works for x.
So negative 6, is that greater
than or less than negative 5?
Well, negative 6 is less
than negative 5, right?
So let me draw the
number line here.
If we have negative 5 here, and
let's just draw a circle around
it because we know it's not
going to be equal to negative 5
because we're deciding between
greater than or less than.
So we're saying 6 works for x.
So negative 6 is here, right?
So negative 6 is less than
negative 5, so is negative 10,
so is negative 100, so is
negative a million, right?
So it turns out that negative
x is less than negative 5.
And this is really all you have
to remember when you are
working with inequalities
in algebra.
Inequalities, you can treat
them just the way-- a greater
than or less than sign, you
could treat them exactly the
way you would treat
an equal sign.
The only difference is, if you
multiply or divide both sides
of the equation by a negative
number, you swap it.
That's all you
have to remember.
Let's do some problems,
and hopefully, that'll
hit the point home.
And if you ever forget, you
just have to try-- you just
remember this: if x is greater
than 5, well, then negative
x is less than negative 5.
And keep trying out numbers.
That's what's going to give
you the best intuition.
Let's do some problems.
So if I said that 3x plus 2 is,
let's say, less than or equal
to 1-- well, this is a pretty
easy equation to solve.
We just say 3x-- let's subtract
2 from both sides, and when you
add or subtract, you don't do
anything to the inequality.
So if you subtract 2 from both
sides, you get 3x is less than
or equal to negative 1, right?
And then, now we're going
to divide both sides by 3.
We get x is less than or equal
to negative 1/3, right?
And notice, we didn't
change anything because
we divided both sides
by a positive 3, right?
We could have actually
done this equation in a
slightly different way.
What if we subtracted
1 from both sides?
So this is another
way of solving it.
What if we said 3x plus 1 is
less than or equal to 0, right?
I just subtracted 1 from both
sides, and now let's subtract
3x from both sides.
And we get 1 is less than or
equal to minus 3x, right?
I subtracted 3x from here, so I
have to subtract 3x from here.
Now, I would have to
divide both sides by a
negative number, right?
Because I'm going to divide
both sides by negative 3.
So I get negative 1/3 on this
side, and based on what we had
just learned, since we're
dividing by a negative number,
we want to swap the
inequality, right?
It was less than or equal,
now it's going to be
greater than or equal to x.
Now, did we get the same
answer when we did it
both-- two different ways?
Here, we got x is less than or
equal to negative 1/3, and
here we got negative 1/3 is
greater than or equal to x.
Well, that's the same answer,
right? x is less than or
equal to negative 1/3.
And that's-- I always
find that to be the cool
thing about algebra.
You can tackle the problem in a
bunch of different ways, and
you should always get to the
right answer as long as
you, I guess, do it right.
Let's do a couple
more problems.
Oh, let's erase this thing.
There you go.
I'll do a slightly harder one.
Let's say negative 8x plus 7
is greater than 5x plus 2.
Let's subtract 5x
from both sides.
Negative 13x plus 7
is greater than 2.
Now, we could subtract
7 from both sides.
Negative 13x is
greater than minus 5.
Now, we're going to divide
both sides of this
equation by negative 13.
Well, very easy.
It's just x, and on this
side, negative 5 divided by
negative 13 is 5/13, right?
The negatives cancel out.
And since we divided by a
negative, we switch the sign.
x is less than 5/13.
And once again, just like the
beginning, if you don't believe
me, try out some numbers.
And I remember when I first
learned this, I didn't believe
the teacher, so I did try out
numbers, and that's how I got
convinced that it
actually works.
When you multiply or divide
both sides of this equation
by a negative sign, you
swap the inequality.
And remember, that's only when
you multiply or divide, not
when you add or subtract.
I think that should give
you a good idea of how
to do these problems.
There's really not
much new here.
You do an inequality-- or I
guess you could call this an
inequality equation-- you do it
exactly the same way you do a
normal linear equation, the
only difference being is if you
multiply or you divide both
sides of the equation by a
negative number, then you
swap the inequality.
I think you're ready now to
try some practice problems.
Have fun.